ninguna declaración o acción del
gobierno iraní parece apaciguar los
ánimos de la gran parte de la población
indignada por la muerte de esta joven de
22 años max a amín y el pasado martes
hoy el jefe de la policía de teherán
aseguró que ninguno de los integrantes
del cuerpo policial había abusado
violentamente de esta joven y el
presidente ibrahim rights y llamó hace
un par de días a su familia diciendo que
llevarían a cabo una investigación hasta
el final y que ella también era su hija
aún así las protestas continúan esto
especialmente en las áreas kurdas en el
noroccidente del país macsa es de una
población llamada saguès y allí
comenzaron las protestas desde el mismo
día de su entierro cientos de personas
cantaron eslóganes muchos de ellos
decían muerte al dictador refiriéndose
al líder supremo de la revolución ali
jamenéi y otras protestas siguieron en
el día de hoy una huelga general en el
comercio de esas grandes ciudades kurdas
y siguen habiendo protestas una
organización de derechos humanos asegura
que en esa región ha habido por lo menos
y ocho personas heridas pero las
protestas también se han extendido
entera no y había una represión violenta
de una manifestación también convocada
en el centro de teherán los vídeos
muestran como la policía atacó con
violencia a muchas mujeres que se
quitaron el pelo y en las grandes
universidades de la ciudad también hubo
protestas esta mañana